david capitan spécialiste de l'allemagne
ancien président de l'université franco
allemande
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france ce soir
racontez nous expliquer le kg et armin
laschet thil est considéré comme le plus
proche d'angela merkel alors ils
achètent effectivement est en tout cas
dans la continuité dans gala merkel
parmi les trois candidats vous l'avez
rappelé qu'ils étaient en lice lors de
la la grande réunion annuelle de la 2cv
ou donc le parti chrétien démocrate
angela merkel qui est au pouvoir depuis
2005 avait annoncé dès 2018 qu'elle ne
se représenterait pas comme tête de
liste pour les élections législatives
qui vont avoir lieu au mois de septembre
il s'agissait donc pour la céder ou
depuis quatre ans maintenant et bien de
lui trouver un successeur alors c'est
quelque chose qu'ils aient fait en
plusieurs étapes dans un premier temps
on la voit sur votre écran d'ailleurs en
bleu c'est madame crâne karine bauer à
quatre cas comme on l'a appelé pour
prononcer son nom plus simplement à
l'étranger avait été retenu et puis
finalement elle a eu l'occasion de
vouloir se distinguer dans gala merkel
et elle a dû renoncer finalement à sa
candidature à partir de 2020 c'est pour
la raison pour laquelle cette année et
bien il fallait lui trouver un
successeur qui est en même temps le
succès du gala merkel et qui portera les
couleurs de la cd ou au mois de
septembre
parmi ces trois candidats donc cette
arme ils achètent qui a qui l'a emporté
c'est le candidat de la continuité alors
c'est un personnage qui vient de qui a
fait sa carrière politique dans la
rhénanie du nord westphalie qui est le
coeur économique de l'allemagne qui est
un des ddd plus gros et au plan
économique ni un des plus gros länder
c'est là que se trouve notamment la la
ruhr avec tout
toute l'industrie allemand c'est donc là
également que se trouve la plus grande
partie de la population allemande
il est donc issu d'une partie très
représentative de l'allemagne cela dit
les deux autres candidats étaient
également émane est également du même
parti dans lui ce qu'il a comme avantage
c'est que il a été
le l'artisan de la victoire de lattes cd
ou en 2017 lors des dernières élections
qui ont eu lieu dans ce land de rhénanie
du nord westphalie c'est une élection
qui était assez disputée à l'époque le
parti au pouvoir était le parti
socialiste et il a réussi à rendre au
parti chrétien démocrate se ce gros
landes extrêmement puissant de
l'allemagne s'est donc assis sur cette
capacité de faire gagner peut-être son
parti lors des prochaines élections que
les délégués alors les délégués donc du
parti qui ont choisi ce le président du
parti l'ont retenu voilà la première
étape en élisant armin laschet tu les
délégués du parti ont fait le choix de
l'expérience de la continuité du
rassemblement à défaut de celui de
l'audace et de la nouveauté c'est ce que
souligne en tout cas aujourd'hui les
commentateurs
quels défis attendent armin achètent je
crois que là le premier défi qui est
auquel il doit faire face ce sont ces
élections quelle est la place de la tse
des oulad cd ou c'est à dire le parti
chrétien-démocrate de madame merkel
ainsi que le parti socialiste qui sont
les deux gros party qui ont structuré la
vie politique allemande depuis la guerre
connaissent un certain essoufflement à
l'heure actuelle qui est due notamment à
la grande coalition qu'ils ont formées
tous les deux depuis maintenant
plusieurs années
cela a favorisé l'émergence de nouvelles
forces politiques
alors le parti d'extrême droite lève des
alternatives für deutschland qui donc se
suit sa route vers l'extrême droite
toujours plus avec une politique 13h
anti migratoires notamment
et puis l'autre force politique qui a
été l'émergence ces dernières années
c'est le parti verts die grünen et donc
tout l'enjeu maintenant pour armes ils
achètent va être de réussir à faire
gagner son parti lors de ces élections
législatives faut savoir qu'en allemagne
évidemment on ne vote pas comme en
france pour le chancelier comme nous
votons pour le président de la
république en allemagne on votera en
septembre pour le parlement et c'est le
parlement ensuite qui élira le
chancelier qui est en réalité
l'équivalent de notre premier ministre
est alors justement d'un mot très
rapidement parce que malheureusement le
temps nous manquait ce qu'il a ses
chances
armin achète de devenir le successeur
dans gala merkel au poste de chancelier
puisqu'on présente donc cette élection
la tête de l'axé des roues comme un
tremplin en anglais
c'est effectivement un tremplin mais
c'est uniquement un tremplin il ya
encore une étape à franchir car en effet
si traditionnellement le président le cd
ou devient le candidat pour les
élections législatives en tout cas la
tête de liste est bien ici les choses
sont plus compliquées cette année car en
effet il ya un autre candidat qui est le
favori dans les sondages et qui est le
président du parti chrétien-démocrate de
bavière car c'est une particularité de
l'allemagne il ya le parti chrétien
démocrate pour l'ensemble de l'allemagne
sauf pour la bavière la bavière à son
propre parti chrétien démocrate
les deux s'unissent pour l'élection
législative et c'est ensemble qu'ils
doivent décider qui sera le candidat
alors est ce que ce sera le candidat de
l'axé d où qu elles plus gros party où
le bavarois il est possible que soit le
bavarois car en effet les pour l'instant
extrêmement populaire encore donc une
interrogation avant de savoir de quelle
manière le parti conservateur se
présentera aux prochaines élections et
nous suivrons ça de très près merci
beaucoup d'avis de capitaux spécialiste
de l'allemagne ancien président de
l'université franco allemande